chaque Americana lavage de cerveau super
économique
parce qu'on écrit avec
des mots d'amour ceux de morceaux de
vent
des arbres qui les reçoivent
pas au crochet
s restantes
à tous ceux qui n'ont plus personne qui
leur arrive
lorsqu'on est connecté
à tous ceux qui n'ont plus personne qui
le rôle
qu'il a écrit
avec les Français
de morceaux de
pain
ne les arbres qui reçoivent
ne les garde pas
les mettre dans de grandes enveloppes de
bruissement de feuilles
de ceux qui n'ont plus personne qui leur
arrive à tous ceux qui n'ont plus
personne
qui leur écrivent
lorsqu'on écrit avec d'invisible pensée
des mots d'amour ceux de morceaux de
bain
les arbres qui les reçoit
ent ne les gardent pas pourquoi c'est
l'oeuvre blanche
il est maintenant
de fleurs et les endroits un poste
restante
à tous ceux qui n'ont plus personne qui
le regardent